en los últimos dos días de capilla
ardiente han venido a saludarle ya
despedirse de él más bien miles de
sudafricanos que se han congregado aquí
en la catedral catedral de san jorge que
es una catedral también conocida como la
iglesia del pueblo por el rol que tuvo
durante la lucha contra la parta y por
ser poco de manifestaciones y protestas
contra el régimen opresor
estoy aquí porque quiero mucho al
arzobispo y su amistad con su santidad
el dalai lama' estuve con él algunas
veces fue una persona de gran
inspiración para mi vida me acompañó en
algunos momentos muy especiales compartí
con él un viaje muy especial en 2016
pero la lucha de desmon tutú trasciende
las fronteras de su país y durante de
sus décadas de activismo dependió
también los derechos de la comunidad
lgtb y de la causa palestina y también
creó conciencia sobre el cambio
climático además apoyó procesos de paz y
reconciliación en países como colombia y
ciudad del sur además de otros países
que se encontraban en conflicto en
diferentes partes del mundo
en nuestra búsqueda por la justicia
queremos ser incluyentes para todos pero
la base para esto es la igualdad debe
ser dignidad debe ser estar libres de la
explotación la base debe ser una
constitución que sea incluyente para
todos
el a sus valores de humildad del
arzobispo desmond tutu que pidió que al
morir se le enterrara en el ataúd más
sencillo y barato posible este ha sido
el caso y hoy en una muy pequeña reunión
en muy pequeña despedida se han aceptado
solamente 100 personas para despedirle
en su funeral son principalmente
miembros de su familia y líderes
políticos sudafricanos sin embargo en
los dos últimos días de capilla
ardiente- miles de sudafricanos de todas
las razas los ámbitos sociales y todos
los ámbitos culturales han venido aquí a
rendirle tributo y a recordar este líder
espiritual y activista por los derechos
humanos y sociales de su país